ecco la guarda che cattiva cucinarsi e
mangiarci ha fatto a pezzi qualcuno l'ha
messo dentro alteri ora che sono tornati
a grandissima richiesta nuovo ep prum
dovremmo scappare dalla baby sitter
cattiva aiuto iter ma nevica sempre
lasciato ben mi piace questo 8 se volete
vedere altri escape romanzi consigliate
se neppure nei commenti tende o miste
guide ancora finito siamo andati a
seguirmi chi non è una lunga storia
sì ovviamente mettetevi comodi preti
poco ordini del giorno abbiamo due
le carica forma di cuoricino alla fine
del video dovremo dare un voto e donald
di cechov skype room e soprattutto
quante cose si sfracella era vitale un
romanzo diciamo loro brunello purità
allora ecco qua vitale beh con le
orecchie da gatto il mio vestito rosa
glitterato fronti allora vediamo cosa
dice o no dice mamma e papà sono
lasciato la peggior baby sitter che c'è
ovviamente dobbiamo prendere noi perché
proviamo e ok siamo scappare forse è
questa la baby sitter guardia c'è
scritto non riuscirò il vaglio stop da
me scritto non toccare queste magliette
e quindi stiamo scappando tipo dalla
nostra casa della nostra cameretta con
gli armadi stai attento a queste bombe
ok poi dovrebbe essere facile facile
piano piano forse meglio saltare non si
credo che la baby sitter di share
vogliono tua cadere ma cosa che succede
non ho capito come abbiamo fatto a
sfracellarsi così ok bisogna evitare il
panico motivo avendo mentre la va anche
al che ha detto dobbiamo uscire fuori
dalla finestra 36
non appena sfracellato sotto la finestra
dove mister e allora sì fuori dalla
finestra da evitare quei party
se c'è un po con sonore scritto bravo se
riuscite a uscire ora troviamo un modo
per uscire da questi ci sarà un
labirinto formarsi di nuovi vestiti
appesi a un labirinto adoro io proprio
andare di qua come preso la prima
vediamo di non perderci eccoti ei no
dove andiamo vediamo forse è così brava
a trovare sintesi si ride alla villa
sappiamo però stiamo attenti sono dei
numeri penso che dobbiamo saltare in
ordine 345 attento google diventa più
difficile e sono sfracellato solo una
volta la futura non è possibile dire che
questo parla mario è molto facile o no
questi di odio ma se stessimo andando
proprio bene in questo
la cena è pronta se ci sono penso che
non sia una buona cena abbiamo vediamo
ma quale sarebbe la sera a questi
aspetti il pezzo di legno
no forse fa dentro vediamo gigante back
di affitto se una cucina esitante stai
attento
cerca di non farti cucinare e la baby
sitter vuole cucinarci per la era facile
piano piano io che sembra che qualcuno
abbia fatto cadere il tè a si guarda se
tutto il tempo di ieri quindi bisogna
stare attenti al traguardo enorme
ecco la guarda che cattiva e così darsi
e mangiarsi non ci pare mai meno male
non si muove come la non accarezza con
lo sanno che c'è qualcuno qua dentro il
31 una zolletta di zucchero ha fatto a
pezzi qualcuno la metto dentro al tele o
uno lo evita ai coltelli
se non si fanno a fettine anche 4 dove
ti aspetto qui silvio scappare che
l'abbiamo fatta tutta la bugia c'è
scritto questa parte della casa sembra
molto bella quella centrale
sì quello sopra o poi facciamo questo no
era sbagliato era detto che sono un bene
sa che dobbiamo stare sopra e non
dovevamo saltare sopra queste palline
dobbiamo evitarle allora piano piano
forse dobbiamo passare altri lati
però questo cammino mi sa che porta da
qualche altra parte
si ok ho capito tipo harry potter
bastiamo nel camino vediamo
eccoci quindi può dire che siamo vicini
alla cena si dovrà andare di qua perché
si provasse a dare ma no non riesco a
dare al loro bisogno effettivo sopra
visti capito da che l'alto forse qui
piano bella scacchiere alto
non mi piace talmente la scacchiera
l'attività fisica e quest'altro
sfracellato italia si sa sfracellando un
bene volta in queste sei chrome quindi
vuol dire che un po più facile usa l'ha
fatta di sfortuna però mai detto quello
che sfugge lato
vitale vuoi farcela poi farlo ce la
vediamo c'è anche un'altra persona
vediamo se riesce a superare vitale e lo
fa solamente volte quante altre volte si
sfracellano dare questa volta ce lo devo
fare bene mancano solo due ma non
abbiamo finito siamo tipo nei
sotterranei cosa qua ci sono delle
piante bisogna stare attenti qui
possiamo sembrano dei sotterranei stai
attento all acqua avvelenata non toccare
l'acqua
piano piano una farsa è finita rizla
fatturato e mortale tutto questo di
fermare attività e poi far sì che ci fa
qui un mobile su realizzando uno stack
la thyssen vedo la fine non ci credo che
ce l'abbiamo già fatta non ci credo
vediamo più attenta è ovviamente
l'ultimo è difficile salviamo subito s'è
scritto grazie per averci aiutato a
prenderla a loro hanno prestato la
babysitter dice questa è la baby sitter
ed e stato arrestato
l'uno è già detta come premio io prendo
per la tipo super veloce sei andato da
un altro scrive trasportato dai vini che
tubetto cdt dice foti ha intrappolato
qua e non c'è modo di scappare
quindi siamo pentiti e uno schifo il
manager della fabbrica ci ha bloccati
dentro
dobbiamo assolutamente uscire da qui ok
proviamoci sopra rufo più difficile cava
in che fabbricazione magiostrina eccoci
qua il prossimo stage allora volta sulla
patatina fritta giusta altrimenti le
altre ti uccideranno acqui centrale
evitare la adora che dei problemi piena
di cibo vita quando si tratta di salvare
la svizzera poiché il prossimo livello è
attenta a queste kakà ball e forse
dobbiamo evitarle ben lo slime è
avvelenato o no alta su queste queste
scatole per riuscire andare dall'altra
parte si dà è facile facile possiamo
farcela
qualcuno ha rotto la macchina del
formaggio quindi non toccarlo ok non mi
chiamo il mare piano piano piano di
meglio evitarlo
piano piano e quell'ora abitare saltarle
[Musica]
no no
metti che finiremo nella bocca di
qualcuno siccome non siamo finiti nella
bocca della bbc parente vede vincere
sapete di cosa stiamo parlando ok vai
pianissimo quando si ma vitale sta
volando
che cosa è successo nella bossi vediamo
che cosa ha mangiato il manager questa
volta sembra che siamo stati mangiati
ovviamente ora vedremo che cosa mangio
ei ma
ma che cos'è questa se mangiato uno
skateboard ma cosa ha aggredito e c'è
qualcosa di strano la partenza di
passare velocemente saltano le
distruzioni ultimamente dove siamo è che
questa cosa ma che cosa hai mangiato
delle perline anni da ma poi è tutto
viola ma vabbè qua è tutto il giallo
vediamo che cosa ci aspetta il laser
bene che sappiano dei locali qualcuno
bisogna passare sotto i laser e immagini
e attento a volte bisogna fare
aiuto va bene andiamo lo vediamo
prossimo stage trova una via d'uscita in
questo labirinto e prova a non toccare
le pareti sono secondo me si sfracellano
forse se riuscita sta la via d'uscita si
bravissima ma non mi dire che siamo già
arrivati quei titoli non è vero troppo
cosa è il pezzo proprie riterini terzo
siamo quasi fuori alta sulle costole
problema perché già l'ho fatta d'accordo
io arriva il pezzo preferito no si
riconosce dal colore ma non può trarre
un po diverso dal solito rosso perché
questo manager mangia qualcosa di strano
è molto più fa male ma siamo finiti un
topo siamo nelle fogne
ok anche cori ma si può saltare sul
topos in un topolino formata da me parla
ma forse un bel abbiamo preso un bel
abbiamo condotto la collezione di pezzi
che piano piano siamo quasi
per fortuna piace questo momento attivi
lo fa e c'è un po di caccetta che è
finita non lo so perché parli dei mostri
dimostri di rene e ovvio che nelle fogne
e ci sia qualche cosa strana e devi
saltare mani perché senza mai fermarsi
attento a non cadere giù io no io seguo
gli altri per capire grazie è difficile
questo camminando sul muro infatti un
sacco di persone stanno flagellando dai
ci siamo quasi
l'abisso fortissimo piano e vitale e
vediamo dove dobbiamo andare adesso
regione ancora finiti quasi quasi quasi
finita stiamo bene
anima dai andiamo me compreso il badge
c'è scritto grazie per aver giocato
abbiamo allora passiamo i voti quella
della baby sitter li do un otto e mezzo
perché mi è piaciuto un sacco che poi
l'abbiamo messo in prigione rossi anche
a farne otto e mezzo su questo del
manager gli do un sette e mezza io
invece gli do un bel 7 voi che voto gli
date queste due skipper lo possiamo
sapere nei commenti
lasciate un vi piace ora cliccate in una
di queste quattro casalinghe su quella
che preferite
buona visione ciao